I have a random question that I've
always been curious about
on Obie trice's album his first album
there's the song we all die one day Tony
Yayo starts off shouting out Soul
assassins and then in my opinion my
favorite Eminem verse ever
he shouts out be real said dog what was
the uh so was there any sort of Soul
assassin's connection with that song
like why was like Tony Yayo shout y'all
out well here's what it was man so that
song was for the next Soul assassin
album
that's so that's what that song was for
we had started it at that time and um
you know and it was like I don't know if
I'm gonna do another one at the time and
then
um Obi was working on his record and
Paul's like hey can we use it for Obi
when it's time to do yours we'll do
another one and I was like absolutely no
problem just push it that way but that's
what that [__] was for crazy so that was
supposed to be on the next solar
assassins though wow when you heard
Eminem's verse on that song because I
think I truly think it's the best Eminem
verse ever and I also think it's
murdered it I think it's the most
underrated song of like that whole era
of like G-Unit Shady Records that song's
so crazy
yeah we was managed by Paul for like six
seven years yeah yeah so at the time you
know he was rolling thick so everything
was in-house back then so we just had uh
names up here shout out to uh yeah I'm
gonna go see him in New York next week I
love names he's great he's just like
kind of just vintage 90s like disrespect
yeah all day long man he told me a story
he was like yeah so you know his lyrics
are this dude I mean his lyrics all the
time are pretty crazy but he was like
Yeah man so like me and Paul went to
Spotify and we're in a room full of like
people played up the album
and he's like that's that was the one
time I felt really awkward because like
I have a song where I'm talking about
slapping the [__] out of women like if
they disrespect it and he's like you
could just see all the women in the
meeting just like be visual like like
visually uncomfortable and he's like I
had to stop it and be like guys this is
all tongue-in-cheek like
like that's the best that's that early
2000s 90s energy yeah man he came with
it on this [__] too boy it was good to
hear yeah for sure man uh what's your
favorite song on the album man
oh [__] I I like them all man I think I
went through periods or this was my
favorite then I recorded this one this
one's my favorite this was my favorite
so right now man I'm just you know out
here just enjoying the [__] record
yeah dude like like let's just be clear
you have Scarface on this album with
Freddie Gibbs you got EV Domo Genesis
Jay worthy tool I mean this is crazy
Method Man is Slick Rick
how do you get slick rick on a record in
2023 just be patient man just be just be
patient I reached out to you know it's
like pretty much man uh the homies all
came through I reached out and said Rick
we're doing this he's a fan yeah a fan
of mine and he should be here he he does
he plays jump around every night in the
show one of his favorite songs ever so
when I reached out and let him know what
I was doing he said yeah I got you
where's the beat gave him the beat
and I had Method Man on it already and
you know that was probably like two
years ago that song has been done I want
to say one of the first singles was the
record with uh be real uh ran and Q
right
um and I remember seeing that and being
like yo you don't see MC Ren's name
anywhere anymore nah like like that
that's a big deal to get him and Cube
together on a song in 2023. yeah yeah
yeah especially with be real like if you
just think about like La hip-hop like
that's a crazy comment that's what I was
thinking like what do we do with this
man like Bieber was on like where do we
go with this song right here and I was
just like yo let's get Cube and ran and
Trey and Snoop and uh Snoop is gonna do
it's just timing just timing you know I
mean I just wanted Dre to talk on the
intros he's like I got you at the time
and I was like I got to turn this [__]
in now but
give me next time
um for you man I feel like your
production style is so unique and it
it's like I feel like you you there's
producers these days I feel like have
kind of lost
the sense of like style at least the
bigger ones like I feel like a lot of
these guys's beats are kind of
interchangeable like you could tell me
that it was produced by this person or
this person like oh yeah but I feel like
DJ mugs your [__] is so like you have
your signature sound like and I'm just
curious like when you first started
making beats what was like your
like where did you draw inspiration from
man like well first you know coming up
man you had to be different and having
your own style you was whack you
couldn't even use a sample somebody used
if you did use garbage
and uh you had to find your own samples
like original samples if somebody was
really digging yeah all those drums they
use those drums there was something
about that you know what I'm saying and
even for Cypress men the way we dressed
the slang we have our own slang you know
dress have our own look have our own
musical style so all that was important
he was whack he was a biter so for me
I was um
I grew up with a lot of classic rock
around and and my mom was in the Motown
so I had a lot of you know psychedelic
classic rock [__] influences Led
Zeppelin Jimi Hendrix but with hip hop
Run DMC LL Cool J Public Enemy and then
everything Molly Maul did every single
Molly mug that came out with back in
those days it seemed like he was
Reinventing the game with every [__]
single you know what I'm saying yeah
when you heard the bridge and then you
heard poison right and then you heard
raw and you was like what the [__] is
this [__] you know what I'm saying and
then uh everything Larry Smith did
you know um ultramagnetics boogie down
Productions like all that [__] right
there was like
all that like mixed up in gumbo and then
going through my filter and spit it back
out